gerücht du bist ex-raucher dass du kein
glück mit beziehungen hat in klammern
nicht böse gemeint habe voll oft gehört
luca wäre deine freunde und ihr wert
schwul 200 herzlich content-anbieter ich
habe heute wieder mein bruder max an
meiner seite und wir machen heute ein
gerüchte über mich video max hat man ins
account haben sie gleich eine frage
gestellt und was uns in fragen tool da
wo immer gerüchte über mich vermutlich
stehe ich konnte mir mitteilen content
max wird jetzt die krassesten auswählen
deswegen macht es auch nicht selbst weil
ich mich natürlich nicht selbst nehmen
würde das ist das ganze prinzip und ich
würde sagen wir reden gar nicht darum
leute letzte gerücht nummer eins dass
die knut flecken die du in den letzten
videos immer mal wieder hatte es von der
unbekannten mit dem zettel sind ja leute
da der stelle kann ich natürlich nach
einer ausgiebigen überprüfung der fakten
zusammen mit meinem wissenschaftlichen
team euch an dieser stelle die
kompression mitteilen ist aber auch ein
sehr gutes gericht es wird gesagt dass
du der regisseur von hilfen leute
erfinden einfach irgendwas
das ist eigentlich eindeutig nein dass
du ein zu wilder typ ist das ist
österreichweit gibt ja ja wo ist die
grenze wo man merkt dass man zu wie das
berechtigte frage nicht ganz geheuer die
spur geht eben zurück in max spieler bei
den kassen bis max wird jetzt die
krassesten auswählende tochter von
ausgabe von oft gehört luca wäre deine
freund und ihr werdet schwul
der gemeine wie woher man so was läuft
mal leute nachts nicht vertragen
hofgasse aus dem stadtteil ruft seine
person so ein seltsamer unbekannte
adresse zusammen
wahrscheinlich hauptbahnhof diesen drei
uhr nachts genau diese sachen passieren
ich kann es gut verstehen
die ärgerte die einzigen ort an den
personen sagen das lokal ich was haben
oder schon mit einer sind sind kein fan
fiction ja also in echt hate to grey g2
aber ein gerücht du bist ex-raucher
effekt es war und es geht weiter warum
hast du angefangen was war der grund zum
aufbau dass das ist eine krasse frage
eigentlich also erst mal vorneweg ich
habe die ganze sache mit dem rauchen ja
geheim gehalten so lange ich es gemacht
habe weil es mir auch schon wichtig ist
dass ihr können auch bundespolitisch
äußert ist ganz klar ihr wisst ja ich
mache mir schon ab und zu mal gedanken
dazu wie ich mich präsentieren was ich
euch so erzählt das tier wollte das
nicht sagen was war mein grund
anzufangen
ganz ehrlich ich habe früher in der
schulzeit nie geraucht ich habe mir der
schulzeit mal eine zigarette probiert
als es auch noch nicht legal war glaube
ich youtube direktor 80 strikes dafür
aber habe aber haben der schutz und die
angefangen zu rauchen aber die sache war
dann eigentlich dann zum studium
weggezogen bin monatlich das muss
intervenieren wird parat wir während der
schulzeit eine feifel gekauft aber keine
stadt sollte so eine richtige mund wir
sowieso in den 60er sowie
schiffskapitäne in 1700 jahren
herrschenden habe mir nur gedacht verrät
märz zieht er dann mit seiner scheiße
los leute ich wollte lg sei nicht wahr
herr ich also 14 15 und wollte ihn wie
so ein bisschen mehr liebt so enthält
alle antworten abgerauscht dass kassel
ich kaufe irgendwelche philosophischen
bücher und der pfeife und dann weg der 6
der pflanzliche habe habe auch die form
zu kommen ich habe damals damit
angefangen weil ich von zu hause
ausgezogen bin und ich glaube in dem
moment habe ich meinem kopf einfach
gedacht ich wohl jetzt alleine ich kann
jetzt zu mir alles so machen wie ich es
will dann ist das auch so eine sache die
ich jetzt mal machen kann weil kein
mensch kontrolliert mich so ich auf
meine alten wohnung war natürlich das
ganze ist ein vier oder fünf jahre
gehalten weil muss man auch sagen in der
uni gerade bei mir viele geraucht haben
das ist richtig gas unter studenten alle
immer selbst gedreht und dann dazu ich
habe damit aufgehört weil es in meinem
umfeld schon länger ein thema war mich
leute immer abgefuckt haben darüber
warum ich eigentlich brauche aber sie
ist doch sehr gut dass man dass ich dich
hab gefragt habt ja ja das eigentlich
schon nach und letzten endes auch hunde
einfach gehabt ja auch hier gut jetzt
hatte ich eine gelegenheit und zwar um
eine kiefer op am kiefer und habe ich
nutze ich das jetzt einfach ich dafür
sowieso ein paar tage nicht rauchen und
sich einfach durch und seitdem hatte ich
keine zeit mehr gehabt das war ein
meister das 19
es geht die nächste vermutung betrifft
auch nicht und zwar dass wir von unseren
eltern viel in den arsch geschoben
bekommen ok wo also ja viele quasi so
verwöhnte hitzig dass das ist das ist
dinger das dass er richtig weiter ok ja
was bericht dazu sagen ich glaube bis zu
einem gewissen punkt ist dass trugen wir
haben schon auf jeden fall auch wir
glück gehabt ich setze leben ist jetzt
keine lotterie oder so aber man kann
sich schon darauf über dankbar für sein
unter welchen bedingungen wir teilweise
aufwachsen durften das auf jeden fall so
es ist nicht so dass wir aber jetzt
irgendwie krass verzogen sind glaube ich
also älter haben uns schon einmal ein
bisschen bisschen maßstab gegeben dazu
es ist jetzt nicht so dass wir mit 18
uns gesagt haben keine ahnung ich wills
eye phone 7 nicht und die bauzeit von
acht oder so was also das nicht ich
würde es glaube ich so beantworten dass
wir schon sehr verwöhnt waren aber nicht
mit materiellen dingen in unserem
privatbesitz also ja ja auch selten
teure handys bekommen wir raten teure
via mini konsole bekommen oder sowas ein
gesetz
anders als unsere kleinen schwester aber
wir haben sehr gut gelebt und ein
schönes haus gehabt und so weiter und so
fort also es geht schon sehr gut aber
ich glaube unsere eltern war es wichtig
dass wir eben nicht verwöhnt sind aber
irgendwie sind wir objektiv schon ein
bisschen verwöhnen körper helfer seien
gerieten deshalb sehr gut gehe auf das
hier ist eine sehr gute frage
das max stärker ist als tun das schreibt
vor allem sogar so ein verteidiger wird
nein also also also ich meine nicht
jemand immer trainiert maxiq sein
training auch durch insofern sind wir
auf einem level vom kraft potenzial her
mag es ja eher sagen weil er hat ein
bisschen lockeren trainingsplan so eine
einheit alle drei wochen ca
ich war schon sein
alle paar monate aktuellen manchmal ist
es auch mehr also es ist sehr sporadisch
bei mir und sebastian zeit voll
kontinuierlich da ja magna den
trainingsplan wo man einmal alle 6
monate zwei wochen jeden tag geht hier
und dann sich aber fünfeinhalb mord
wiederholten ganz genau so das prinzip
ich bin dann immer auf so einem plateau
das kennen die leute vielleicht die auch
im fitness machen nächstes gerücht dass
du kein glück mit beziehungen hat in
klammern nicht böse gemeint
das hätte da er soll sogar den angeblich
will ich setze ich so emotional schon
jetzt eine ganz schwierige frage ganz
ehrlich subjektive einschätzungen glück
mit beziehungen ein
nein ich denke also über die frage an
sich nach so was was heißt das heißt
glück im mit beziehung so das heißt dass
man das einige leute aus dass man glück
ein fahrer zufällig jemanden treffen der
perfekt passend also dass ich mache also
auch mit enttäuscht
man kann ja auch häufig nur bedingt was
dafür
ach so ja wo dann vielleicht schon dann
würde ich schon sagen dann kein glück
erwartet eine freundin hat erzählt dass
du mal vor gestraft wurde deswegen
sexuell missbraucht was einfach mal
rufmord läge aber jetzt auch verstehen
wir nachhaltig weiß dass er das thema
aber das ist aber so geisteskrank
das ist vorbestraft binya geiger der
wahl weder bei der tat noch bei der
verhandlung noch bei der verurteilung
dabei es war aber klar manchmal passiert
es dass man all das man straftaten
begeht und verurteilt wird und
verhandelt wird ohne dass man dabei ist
dass es kann passieren dass auch nicht
versuchen also nein neiße vermutung hier
gewiss keine emotionale mensch bei
traurigen film effekt würde schon sagen
'ja ja nicht so über kraft
ja das ist das ist immer so eine frage
von dem welchem moment mal ich erwischte
ganz ehrlich ich gehe mal zu filme rein
und ja dann kriegt man schon manchmal
kicks mich ein bisschen mehr aber ich
habe jeden fall manche momente der
gewisse themen catchen nicht einfach und
dann bin ich wirklich so krass drin so
was wie patriotismus also quasi so
nationalstolz das was mich irgendwie
voll erwischt dann um menschen die
irgendwie besonders aufopferungsvoll für
andere sind wenn ihr wenn ich davon
beispiele sevilla das gibt nicht so weit
da gibt's ich habe also ein video auf
youtube gesehen da ging es mir darum
dass eine familie die schon sechs kinder
hat und irgendwie schon krasse der
armutsgrenze lebt mitbekommen hat dass
ihre nachbarn oder die mutter
nachbarhaus die alleinerziehend ist mit
zwei kindern an krebs erkrankt dass man
gestorben ist und dann haben die einfach
noch mal die anderen zweck hinter
aufgenommen ich wollte das jetzt weisen
ausgeht haben wir mit acht kindern
zugeschlagen und die haben
durchgestanden und ihr mann sowieso eine
hausrenovierung bekommt von seiner
fertig wurde das ist da will ich auch
nein du hast du mit max freundin schläft
ja ich wollte ja eigentlich nicht wenn
man nicht diese zeit ich sagen aber
irgendwas ist ja auch aus ist natürlich
die wahrheit liebe grüße dich du bist
bisexuell selbstverständlich nein also
bis dato wurde war nicht bekannt dass
ich bisexuell bedeutet dass vielleicht
seitdem ihr auch da wieder ein stück
voraus vielleicht ist es so eine sache
wie mit mit dem einen fall wo ich ja
auch eine straftat begangen hat nicht
weil der fahndung da war und auch nicht
beim urteil aber es war trotzdem ich
möglicherweise geht es auch darum mehr
also du hast mit minderjährigen groupies
geschlafen da gibt es kursieren einige
solcher geschichten leider in youtube
preise aber wir sind glaube ich beide so
was immer
mit absolutem unverständnis begegnet
gerücht du bist ein charmeur und biss
nicht von size zero mädels überzeugt und
dann steht da bälle boulevardmagazin als
es komplett wird formuliert aber er ist
kein seriöser super dünne models werk
kvasiny das ist kann er auch jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden
ich sage nicht dass frauen so sein
müssen wie ich besser finde ich kann
mich besser findet und so ganz ganz
dünnen so in dem sinne also ich meine
das ja wirklich schon sehr sehr hart an
der grenze zu einem gesunden körper team
ist nicht meins das ist schon irre
können musst du musst du sein
gelegentlich vielleicht will ich bin das
ist okay das war auch schon das letzte
gerücht was ich finden konnte was
machbar war auf jeden fall van ihr
einiges neues rausgekommen warum
materiell ich das video schon so weit
ich hier über meistens gesicht einfach
vorgeschlagen dass die option könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren bisschen an
dieser stelle raus leute scheint mir die
kommentare osten bereiten hat und wenn
man es gut leute heute leider kennt